bienvenue dans ce journal sur ce cas tu
vis présenté par Monsieur wild tu vas
bouger la rallonge
tu vas bouger la rallonge avec ces gens
des choses vous voulez que la chaîne
soit sur
[Musique]
n'hésitez pas le samedi 22 octobre à 11h
une merveilleuse visite des collections
du palais Millenium
[Musique]
une des rares ici sculptures qui était
dans le bureau de Napoléon 1er dans son
cabinet de travail au palais des
Tuileries commandé en 1808 ce trésor a
accompagné Napoléon jusqu'à l'Elysée et
ensuite a été donné au prince Eugène de
Warner son beau-fils si vous voulez en
savoir plus et avoir beaucoup d'objets
rendez-vous le 22 octobre à 11h au
palais Vivienne si on
[Musique]
va pas le
[Applaudissements]